[Musica]
per provare ad introdurvi nel mondo
della natura imperfette di cui vi voglio
parlare
cercherò di raccontarvi quello che
capita nel in un minuto della vita di
ciascun essere umano in un minuto si
compiano dai 12 ai 20 atti respiratori
respirare un atto involontario e che
viene fatto da tutti voi senza alcuno
sforzo e senza prestarvi attenzione
forse sì prestate attenzione perché me
ne sto parlando
per alcune persone come per me respirare
invece è sempre stato un atto a cui mi
dovevo obbligare e darà una necessità
che il mio corpo pretendeva e che io
dovevo colorare con ogni volta ogni tre
secondi
cercate di immaginare che il vostro
respiro sia gravato da una pietra sul
torace e che d'aria che cercate di
respirare non sia un fluido trasparente
e impalpabile ma si sa qualcosa di dense
colloso come fango questo è stato per me
respirare per la gran parte della mia
vita
una condanna una fatica una prigione
senza la via d'uscita che si ripeteva
uguale a se stessa ma ogni volta più
aspre più difficile ogni tre secondi 20
volte in un minuto circa 30.000 volte in
un giorno per per un moto perpetuo e
assolutamente senza una possibilità di
remissione l'idea di imperfezione che
vorrei comunicarvi è insita nelle radici
più profonde della nostra cultura che
risale al pensiero ellenico da ippocrate
quinto secolo avanti cristo fondatore
della medicina occidentale fino ad
arrivare a noi
questi dati imperfezione ed è un'idea
radicale diverso da quella di malattia
viene teorizzato che la natura vuole
operare un suo prodotto perfetto che
l'uomo ma ha in sé una
intrinseca contraddizione perché la
materia che utilizza caduca organi
cellule muscoli sono tutti destinati ad
una fine per cui il progetto che
vorrebbe essere perfetto ha una sua
intrinseca imperfezione dentro di sé io
sono affetto dalla nascita da una
malattia genetica che si chiama fibrosi
cistica è una malattia degenerativa e ad
esito infausto muoverò non c'è una cura
detta così può essere una
esemplificazione della vita di ciascuno
tutti quanti noi tutti quanti voi si
nasce si vive e si muore
la differenza in meno nelle persone come
me che hanno una imperfezione in tono
maggiore è che rendiamo più evidente
questa imperfezione questa caducità la
mia vita procede ad una velocità diversa
e maggiore della nostra perché o meno
tempo a disposizione e soprattutto il
senso di caducità è più evidente ed è
più aspro e depurativo
io credo che il bisogno essenziale di
ciascun uomo sia la libertà
per me la la libertà e questo sono spazi
spazio in cui potersi muovere la
malattia che con cui mi confronto dalla
nascita esige ogni giorno grandi
sacrifici e impone grandissimi lipidi
quindi è un antitesi della libertà
io non sono stato libero perché sono
stato vincolato dai vincoli dai limiti
del mio corpo e non sono stato libero
perché ho trascorso un lungo tratto
della mia vita in ospedale ho 47 anni e
si mette insieme tutto il periodo tutti
i periodi nel tempo che ho trascorso in
ospedale
forse cinque anni li ho trascorsi
all'interno di una stanza d'ospedale
altro tempo l'ho trascorso a casa
facendo terapie limitante attaccato la
pompa di infusione una macchina per la
respirazione non invasiva
l'ultimo tratto della della mia vita di
confronto più aspro con la malattia
quando la malattia era arrivata a un
punto terminale
ho dovuto fare uno stage alla terapia
sulle 24 ore per oltre un anno sono
stato legato a plasticamente ad un
oggetto che era una bombola alle volte
due bombole di ossigeno un tubo la
maschera quando era legato a queste
bombole avevo al massimo un autonomia di
un'ora un'ora e mezza per poter uscire
di casa nelle giornate meno aspre con
quelli in cui avevo bisogno di ribadire
me stesso di sapermi vivo riuscirò alle
volte a uscire di casa appunto andare in
montagna
alle volte sono riuscito anche a sciare
e pur con uno spazio limitato di tempo
un'ora un'ora e mezza è un grande
vincono vi posso garantire che avevo
tutto il mondo a mia disposizione è vero
tutta la libertà di cui potevo avere
voglia pur all'interno di questo questa
bolla d'aria che era contenuto in un
oggetto sull'altro sulla mia schiena
io ho tentato di rendere possibile e
vivibile la mia esistenza cercando di
convogliare dall'esterno verso l'interno
tutto il meglio che i progressi
tecnologici e scientifici soprattutto in
campo medico era la disposizione facendo
questo ho cercato di superare dei limiti
che la la mia vita e la mia fisicità mi
ponevano se mi guardo intorno e penso a
voi alle persone che sono cosiddette
sale vi immagino già libere vi immagino
già
portatrice noi stesse di tutto quanto è
necessario
io vi dico ho cercato di convogliare
dall'esterno verso l'interno di energia
e potenza possibilità per ampliare gli
spazi della mia libertà e facendo questo
ho attinto appunto al meglio delle
risorse in campo medico farmacologico
tecnico scientifico penso che a molti
capiti di fare un percorso verso chi è
sano ha a disposizione un patrimonio
infinito che però da per assoluto per
certo e per alle volte intangibile e
questo può portare ad una
sottovalutazione della realtà delle
proprie possibilità e delle proprie
potenzialità ea concepire un percorso
inverso d'essere cercare all'esterno
cercare qualche cosa che dia
realizzazione soddisfazione ai propri
bisogni
fuori di sé ma solamente in questo in
questa fase di sviluppo socio economico
della nostra società che pone crea nuovi
bisogni al di fuori di noi stessi le
persone sane che sono portate a dare per
scontata la propria salute
esteriorizzando a questi bisogni pieno
fanno sicuramente in assoluta buona fede
e anche con un grado di consapevolezza
credo forse alle volte ma del costo
credono di poter governare questo
meccanismo e di utilizzare la tecnologia
per le proprie soddisfazioni ma non si
rendono conto che in questo modo
all'iran parte della propria libertà
vi faccio un esempio molto banale queste
sono le mie montagne
io ho iniziato arrampicare e a salire la
montagna con gli sci d'alpinismo più di
30 anni fa
trent'anni fa non c'erano mezzi di
comunicazione e portatili si partiva la
mattina si tornava la sera o il giorno
dopo è l'unica un l'unico modo di
comunicare per esempio con con casa era
un telefono da un rifugio di montagna
erano le stesse le difficoltà erano le
stesse la libertà con cui si
affrontavano determinati spazi credo
fossero gli stessi
oggi tutti girano come telefono in tasca
in città il telefono funzione montagna
trasformano funziona quasi mai essere in
montagna avere un telefono non poterlo
usare riduce la propria libertà invece
che ampliarla perché io so che mia
moglie che a casa che mi aspetta se non
sente se non mi sente si preoccupa io ho
uno strumento che dovrebbe renderli
libero e investo qualche cosa su di lui
è in realtà riduce i miei spazi di
libertà e gli ambiti di libertà
il mio bisogno di grandi spazi viene
limitato da qualche cosa che è un
bisogno indotto da una tecnologia 30
anni fa potevo stare fuori un giorno
intero senza sentirmi in difetto nei
confronti di chi a casa mi aspettava
oggi se per ora so che so un punto morto
di ricezione mi sento non più libero
questo può accadere ed è un
un'alienazione di propri spazi di
libertà che è il contrario di quello che
bisognerebbe volere e dovere fare io non
posso essere un critico radicale e tukur
della tecnologia
io vivo grazie alla tecnologia vi dicevo
ai progresso il medico scientifici
all'evoluzione dei farmaci soprattutto e
ad alcune tecniche operatorie io da sei
anni e mezzo vivo grazie al trapianto
bipolmonare che all'apparenza è il
risultato appunto di del meglio della
tecnica chirurgica attualmente
esistente di tecniche di rianimazione di
tecnica di conservazione rigenerazione
degli organi espiantati queste
tecnologie esistono la tecnologia è
neutra assume un significato e una
valenza solo nella sua applicazione
la tecnologia non è un qualcosa che ha
una ragione in se stessa anche se
all'apparenza viene venduta così per
questo è capace di generare bisogni
indotti a non necessari io vi dico vivo
grazie al trapianto bipolmonare grazie
all'abilità di un chirurgo e grazie ad
una serie infinita è enorme di progresso
il medico scientifici ma tutto questo
non sarebbe stato né sufficiente nel
necessario né utile né applicabile se
prima di tutto questo non ci fosse stato
il gesto di uomo che ha deciso di donare
qualcosa ad un altro uomo
due uomini io alla fine della mia vita
dopo una lunga malattia ed un altro uomo
che alla fine della sua vita arrivato
per caso e provincia un po del destino
queste due umanità hanno potuto fondersi
e dare un senso un significato
necessario ad un processo tecnologico e
per questo che io immagino il sentono
l'umanità attuale come non un insieme
non dell'insieme genera generalizzato
degli uomini io penso sempre a l'uomo
come all'altro dall'ala la persona che
posso vedere l'altro da me la parte
migliore di me sa che a mia moglie irene
qui eravamo due giorni prima della
chiamata del trapianto con l'ossigeno
e i fiori uno è mia moglie l'altro avuto
riparo perché non li avesse saputo di
scure questo sommario in montagna con
l'ossigeno l'altro da me sono i miei
compagni di di montagna che mi hanno
sempre spronato ad essere migliore e più
forte di me stesso e superare i miei
limiti e mi hanno imposto di
confrontarmi con dei limiti che sono
assolutamente oggettivi la montagna alta
un metro o quattromila metri è uguale
per tutti non concede nessuna
differenziazione si pone in modo
assolutamente libero e neutrale nei
confronti di chi la vuole salire in
questa foto sono con il mio doppio che è
un amico trapiantato e se guardate bene
siamo in quattro noi due e le due
persone che hanno deciso di permetterci
di vivere ancora per questo voglio dirvi
un'ultima cosa sul sul trapianto e su
che cosa può significare io lo so nulla
della della persona che ha donato parte
di sede l'uomo senza nome che respira in
quando si viene chiamati si conoscono
solo sesso età ad altezza per le
caratteristiche morfologiche
io sono una di voi ma voi oggi avete
ascoltato la sua voce perché ricordando
benvenuto iniziale ognuno di noi
respirano e l'aria che fa muovere le
corde vocali
io non so nulla di lui ma voi avete
ascoltato la sua voce oggi questa è la
mia ultima montagna e i miei 4000 metri
dedicati all'uomo senza nome che
respirarla questo è il mio pensiero si
nasce non soltanto per morire ma per
camminare a lungo con piedi che non
conoscono dimore vanno oltre ogni
l'umanità che verrà sarà sempre solo
fatta dagli uomini che sapranno
riconoscere al di là del più grande e
più roboante più enorme progresso
scientifico una mano tesa tra uomo ed un
altro uomo
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]